casi todo lo que hace un químico
consiste en mezclar cosas juntas de
alguna manera así que pensé que ahora
sería un buen momento para introducir
algunas ideas y terminologías que
involucren mezclas antes que apuntarlo
mezclas
class ok y de hecho mezclar es una
palabra muy extensa así que en esta
ocasión voy a hablar de mezclas
homogéneas homogeneizar implica que se
hicieron homogéneas así que déjame
ponerlo am con este color mezclas
homogéneas
je
homogéneas y lleva acento justo aquí ok
es decir vamos a hablar acerca de las
mezclas homogéneas y probablemente te
estés preguntando bueno que significa
homogéneo homogéneo significa uniforme o
consistente en todas partes que no hay
mucha variación en la propia mezcla la
palabra más común o el ejemplo más común
de esto es la leche de cabra o la leche
de vaca la leche homogeneizada leche
mesada ok y bueno es que no sé si has
tenido el privilegio de ordeñar
directamente a una vaca oa una cabra
pero si lo haces encontrarás que la
grasa de la leche
de haan dibujará que un vaso la grasa de
la leche y la grasa
bueno no láctea se separan muy rápido es
decir tenemos aquí en la parte superior
la grasa de la leche y después aquí
tengo a todos los demás de la leche así
que esto es regular y sale directamente
de la ubre de la vaca tendrás una capa
de grasa que es la que se muestra aquí
arriba y todas estas cosas aquí son
mucho más líquidas la leche
homogeneizada se asegura de que toda
esta grasa esté dispersa uniformemente y
por completo en nuestro vaso de leche es
decir aunque todo esté lleno de una
mezcla homogénea esta grasa se dispersa
uniformemente por completo a través de
todo este vaso es por esto que cuando
vas a la tienda lo que
y compras leche homogeneizada todo es
cremoso y agradable en ella que es este
caso de aquí y no tienes este brillo
agradable de la grasa en la parte
superior y bueno todo se ve mucho más
homogéneo así que esto es lo que
significa homogeneizada de modo que una
mezcla homogénea es la misma cosa
uniforme y consistente en todas sus
partes bueno ahora todo está mucho más
dividido si lo pensamos en términos del
tamaño de las partículas que se diluyen
en la mezcla de modo que si tenemos una
situación en donde las partículas son
más grandes que 500 nanómetros
y déjame ponerlo así más grandes que 500
ok nanómetros nada no metros y ojo esto
puede ser que suene muy grande pero
todavía no es tan grande porque un
nanómetro es una millonésima parte de un
metro bien pero lo importante es que si
tenemos partículas mezcladas no sé se me
ocurre en agua de hecho no tienen que
ser agua
no necesariamente tiene que ser una
mezcla en un fluído pero si estas
partículas son mayores que 500
nanómetros entonces estamos hablando de
una suspensión y déjame ponerlo así sus
ok y una suspensión la voy a tratar de
explicar con un ejemplo que tenga más o
menos aquí
imagínate que aquí tengo un vaso con
agua aquí tengo el vaso y esto es agua
ahora imagínate que tengo algunas
partículas grandes por aquí estas estas
que se ven más o menos aquí estas
partículas pueden ser que después de un
tiempo se precipiten al fondo de este
recipiente se precipiten al fondo de
este caso o bueno de hecho algunas veces
flotarán en la parte superior
dependiendo de su flotabilidad es decir
si son más pesados o más ligeros que el
agua de esto depende si flotaran en la
parte superior o se depositarán en la
parte inferior y ahora con el fin de
recuperar el estado de la suspensión lo
que tienes que hacer es agitar la
botella o el vaso o lo que tengas aquí
de modo que puedo pensar algunos
ejemplos sobre esto a mí se me ocurre
que la primera mezcla que me viene a la
cabeza es la pintura la pintura la
pintura mezclada de acuerdo antes de que
pintar las paredes tienes que asegurarte
de que la lata está
de lo contrario vas a tener una capa
inconsistente ahora otro ejemplo y esto
está muy cerca de mi corazón y es la
leche con chocolate y es más déjeme
ponerla de este color la leche leche con
chocolate con chocolate chocolate está
me encanta y bueno aquí tengo el leche
entonces si nosotros le ponemos
chocolate más o menos se ve así una
leche con chocolate y está que tengo más
o menos aquí cuando la revuelves tienes
estos pequeños grumos de chocolate en la
leche y se haber riquísimo al menos
cuando el globo el chocolate luce más o
menos así pero si se deja reposar por un
tiempo largo eventualmente todo el
chocolate se asienta en la parte
inferior del vaso empieza a asentarse en
esta parte de aquí en realidad en
diferentes partes de él hay veces que se
agrupan en la parte superior he visto
situaciones en las que el azúcar se
acomoda en el fondo y bueno estos grupos
la parte de arriba también
pero es importante de esto es que tengas
la idea de que la mezcla se separa y
esto es porque las partículas ya sean de
pintura o de leche con chocolate son
mayores a 500 nanómetros
ahora si llegamos a un rango quizá un
poco más pequeño a mí se me ocurre ahora
pensar en un rango a vámonos para acá de
2 500 nanómetros de 2 a 500 ok
nanómetros nanómetros bueno en este caso
estamos hablando de un color de amd de
un color de ok y justo esta es una
palabra que se me hace muy chistosa
cuando yo estaba en clases de ciencia
platicaba con un amigo que esta palabra
la palabra coloide me resultaba más
apropiada para no ser algún tipo de
problema gastrointestinal o algo así
pero no realmente no es un problema
gastrointestinal realmente un coloide es
un tipo de mezcla homogénea donde las
partículas son lo suficientemente
para que queden suspendidas así que tal
vez podría llamarlo a una suspensión
mejor o una suspensión permanente y
bueno para hacer esto vamos a dibujarlo
de esta manera imagínate que yo me tomo
aquí am tengo ahora un vaso con agua
ok este es mi vaso con agua y recuerda
que no forzosamente debe de ser agua
podría ser aire o lo que sea donde ahora
las moléculas son lo suficientemente
pequeñas como para suspenderse en este
fluido que tenemos aquí así que las
fuerzas entre partículas y las fuerzas
am inter moleculares superan esta idea a
esta tendencia de las partículas de
querer salir de esta solución en
cualquier dirección y bueno al menos el
ejemplo más común que siempre pienso
cuando pienso en un coloide es la
gelatina y déjame ponerlo con este color
la
tina y es que la gelatina en un
principio es un polvo que permanece
suspendido en el agua y después puedes
dejarlo en el refrigerador no sé para
siempre y sencillamente nunca se va a
volver a separar ese polvo y nunca va a
querer salir fuera de la gelatina otro
ejemplo que se me ocurre es la niebla la
en este caso tenemos moléculas de agua
dentro de una mezcla de aire y después
también tenemos otra que es muy parecida
que es el humo
cuando me refiero al humo estoy hablando
también de un aerosol la niebla y el
humor son aerosoles y bueno este aerosol
habla de un líquido en el aire mientras
que en este estamos hablando de un
sólido en el aire el humo solo tiene que
ver con las pequeñas partículas obscuras
aunque aparecen siempre flotando
alrededor del aire y bueno nunca saldrán
del aire o son lo suficientemente
pequeñas que simplemente siempre a
flotar han alrededor y con el aire ahora
pensemos qué es lo que pasa si tenemos
algo menor a 2 nanómetros y déjenme
poner este para acá y bueno déjame
borrar esta parte de aquí creo que
necesitamos espacio y bueno voy a quitar
esta leche homogeneizada así que vamos a
quitar todo esto ok y ahora que ya lo
quitamos vamos a empezar a hablar de
soluciones y es que si tenemos
partículas menores a 2 nanómetros
y déjenme ponerlo con este color ok si
tengo algo que sea menor
nanómetros ok a esto se le conoce como
una solución así que déjenme ponerlo con
este color son
ilusión ok y bueno seguramente te vas a
preguntar qué es una solución pero antes
de eso quiero que observes tu mundo
cotidiano es decir quiero que veas a tu
alrededor y te preguntes en tu casa o en
donde estés
qué cosas encuentras que sean
suspensiones y bueno de hecho lo primero
que te podrás preguntar es si es una
mezcla homogénea y después si es una
suspensión eventualmente va a estar en
el estado que se encuentra o después voy
a tener que agitarlo después podrías
pensar qué pasa con los coloides y bueno
recuerda que los coloides son en el caso
en el que ese estado se mantendrá
durante mucho tiempo o podría ser una
solución y una solución probablemente es
lo más importante en química aunque la
gente habla sobre colo hoy de
suspensiones el 99% de todo lo que
hablaremos en química involucra
soluciones y en general cuando hablamos
de soluciones hablamos de soluciones
acuosas cuando añades algo al agua eso
significa acuoso así que si de plano
alguno
es algo común tengo x x en estado acuoso
es decir hace y cerramos el paréntesis
cuando hablo de un compuesto y lo pongo
entre paréntesis hacen significa que
esté compuesto x está disuelto en agua x
paréntesis hace o hay veces que se pone
x paréntesis a y eso quiere decir que x
es un absoluto con agua como solvente y
creo que estas dos definiciones son muy
importantes saber que es un absoluto y
déjame ponerlo así un soluto ok y que es
un solvente y bueno un absoluto lo
podemos pensar como a la cosa que se
disolvió así que déjenme escribirlo así
el solución es la cosa ok que se
disolvió qué
disolvió de sol vio ok mientras que el
solvente
y déjame ponerlo con otro color cuando
hable del solvente solvente ok no
podemos pensar de la siguiente manera un
solvente que bueno amén y dos agua un
solvente es lo que está en mayor
cantidad o puedes pensar en esto como la
cosa que está en todo alrededor o la
cosa que está haciendo la disolución así
que déjame escribir lo mejor así la cosa
ok que hace la disolución que que hace
hace la disolución disolución ok
estos dos conceptos son muy importantes
por ejemplo y se me ocurre pensar en el
cloruro de sodio en una solución acuosa
antes de ponerlo aquí en am cl ok en
agua
ok una solución acuosa lo que quiere
decir que es en agua y lo que está
pasando es que las partículas del sodio
y del cloro se están dispersando
recuerda unión se lo quitó del átomo de
sodio pero cuando lo pones en presencia
del agua y recuerda que el agua se veía
más o menos así tú tienes aquí un
hidrógeno ok
aquí tienes el oxígeno aquí tienes otro
hidrógeno
déjame dibujar otro aquí tienes el
oxígeno otro hidrógeno por aquí otro
hidrógeno y recuerda que aquí tienes una
carga parcial positiva ok en los
hidrógenos y aquí tienes una carga
parcial negativa esto lo he hecho un
montón de veces positiva am positiva ok
y bueno aquí tienes una carga parcial
negativa y esto hace que el cat ión de
sodio and se sienta atraído por los
oxígenos del agua así que a mí déjame
tomarlo con este color sí con este color
pongo aquí al sodio entonces aquí tengo
al sodio y el sodio se sienten han
atraído por
estos oxígenos del agua y ya te
imaginarás después el cloro el a nyon
negativo será atraído por los extremos
del hidrógeno del agua eso es lo que
realmente le permite que se consiga
disolver porque estos iones tienen algo
de carga les gusta mezclarse con el agua
así que si con este color
yo pongo aquí que se sienten atraídos ok
y bueno también con este color
pensamos cerca del cloro bueno el cloro
am se va a ver más o menos como por aquí
aquí vamos a tener al claro y recuerda
que tiene una carga negativa y de igual
manera aquí aquí tengo el cloro con una
carga negativa y todo esto me da bien
aquí tengas la idea de cuánto es dos
nanómetros esto sigue siendo bastante
grande le permite las moléculas tener un
buen número de átomos ésta es una cosa
que es muy importante darnos cuenta
cuando hablamos de una solución por
ejemplo si piensas en un átomo bastante
grande como el átomo de cesio que es uno
de los más grandes que puedas encontrar
el sitio que es un átomo bastante
de grande tiene un orden de 2.6 amstrong
tiene un orden de 2.6 amstrong strong ok
y bueno de hecho un ancestro para que te
des cuenta de la magnitud de lo que
estamos hablando es una décima parte de
un nanómetro es decir que el cesio tiene
un orden de 1.26 nanómetros es decir muy
pequeño así que por ejemplo si querías
que una molécula que podría salir del
estado de esta solución y entrar al de
coloide pues necesitaría a un montón de
estos átomos de cesio de estas esferas
de cesio porque realmente si nos fijamos
en una solución
estamos hablando de moléculas de 22
nanómetros y está genial lo que quiere
decir que caben cerca de 7 átomos de
cesio para cada una de estas moléculas
que tenemos en una solución incluso más
que eso especialmente si tienes átomos
muy pero muy pequeños como el hidrógeno
pero bueno ahora viene una siguiente
pregunta como
cada una de estas cosas es decir como
mides en cada una de estas
concentraciones dicho de otra manera
tenemos varias formas de medir la
concentración de hecho en este momento
vamos a usar una de ellas la cual por
cierto es la fracción molar antes de
ponerlo así la fracción que mola
y bueno que es la fracción molar bueno
la fracción molar se define como los
moles de solutos amperio ponerlos y la
cantidad a ok de moles moles de soluto
de su luto ok esto soluto dividido entre
la cantidad de moles totales es decir de
la solución de entera o lo podemos ver
así como la cantidad ok de moles moles
de solutos soluto más bueno pues la
cantidad de moles ok del solvente am de
soul 20 de solvente es decir la cantidad
de moles totales que hay déjame hacer
esta línea hasta acá eso es lo que
significa fracción molar y quiero que
recuerdes que ya la utilizamos cuando
nosotros mismos los problemas de presión
parcial porque con el fin de averiguar
la presión parcial de algo de cifras te
lo que es la presión total y después
dijiste cuál es
fracción molar de el oxígeno por ejemplo
por decir algo en la mezcla y entonces
multiplicas t eso por la presión parcial
y tuviste la fracción molar ahora una de
las que se muestran mucho en química son
la palabra polaridad a polaridad
polaridad y hay que tener cuidado porque
ésta se confunde mucho con la siguiente
palabra modalidad modalidad y lo voy a
poner con este color
mulally that ok son dos palabras
distintas y no se deben de confundir la
polaridad suena como la más indicada
porque tienen la palabra molar adentro
de lo cual lo hace bastante intuitivo a
esta palabra que tiene adentro molar lo
cual no es tan intuitivo pero en mi
cabeza siempre que pienso en la palabra
polaridad recuerdo que tal vez no sea la
mejor medición y bueno es que esta se
define como la cantidad ok de moles
es del soluto ok de solutos soluto ya
esto lo dividimos lo dividimos entre la
cantidad de litros de litros de la
solución total de la solución ok así es
como se define molar y that y la razón
por la que no me gusta en la modalidad
es porque los litros de la solución no
son en variantes cambian cierto es decir
esta parte de aquí no siempre es la
misma ya hemos aprendido esto muchas
veces ya sabes bebe es igual
nr t el volumen puede variar con la
presión y la temperatura así que la
modalidad va a variar con la presión y
la temperatura para la misma solución si
solamente tomas la misma solución y las
llevas a denver o no ser al valle de la
muerte la polaridad de la solución va a
cambiar así que para mí esto no es tan
satisfactorio y pensar en ella como la
medida de la concentración no es lo
mejor en cambio si pensamos en la
moralidad
mucho más útil al menos en mi opinión la
moralidad la podemos definir am y dejame
poner con este mismo color como la
cantidad ok de moles de moles de su luto
también soluto date cuenta que tenemos
la cantidad de moles de soluto
también aquí también aquí de hecho el
numerador en estos tres casos es
esencialmente el número de partículas
que tenemos y esto dividido entre la
masa del solvente
o los kilogramos déjame ponerlo así del
solvente solvente y bueno la razón por
la que yo creo que esta es mucho mejor
que la molar y that es porque no importa
a donde vayas
si estás en denver o en el valle de la
muerte los moles no van a cambiar en
todos pero la masa tampoco cambia y
ahora la presión y el volumen y la
temperatura podrían cambiar pero la masa
no va a cambiar a menos que estás
agregando más o menos solvente así que
para mí esta es la mejor del
2 ok la modalidad que la polaridad y de
hecho voy a poner un pequeño concurso en
este vídeo para ver si todos ustedes
pueden pensar de buenas maneras para
recordar la diferencia entre modalidad y
modalidad si pueden recordar bien cuáles
son las diferencias y es que francamente
pienso que es una de las cosas que más
pueden confundir a las personas
especialmente si llevan uno o dos años
sin tomar clases de química aunque bueno
esto no debería de ser confuso ya que
simplemente son dos definiciones
distintas si alguien dice cuál es la
diferencia entre modalidad y modalidad
tú dirás hoy era una diferencia con el
volumen y la masa pero no recuerdo cuál
es cuál así que les dejo a ustedes
chicos que piensen en una buena forma
para memorizar la diferencia entre estas
dos nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo